you want to sell the vacation not the
plane flight a lot of people when they
want to sell stuff they talk about the
widgets they talk about checking their
bag and taking their shoes off and who
they're going to sit next to on the
plane and the seat and how long the
flight's going to be but people just
want Maui you should be describing the
beach and the ocean what they're going
to experience the moment they get into
the hotel room that's what we should
describing not how they're going to get
there once you sell the vacation that's
when you make the ask if they don't say
yes immediately totally reasonable most
people don't then we walk them through
making the decision-making process